[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 112
that's right which is not a prime number
i mean for many reasons but primarily
because it's even
is there a primarily and not being a
prime
it's an interesting question i mean my
guess is mathematically no yeah but uh
you think so all reasons that you're not
prime are equal yeah but you know the
eyes of the lord let's give me a break
as an ape i'm using heuristics it's a
good one you know i mean it only fails
in that one case and you could just kind
of remember that yeah yeah that's true
that's true
so we're coming to you early this week
for those of you watching live you are
already well aware of that um and it's
it's late afternoon on a friday so i
don't know i don't know what that means
about the tenor the tenor here it's been
it's been a long two years
it has been a long two years it's been
kind of a long day it's been a long week
it's already been a long month even
though it's only half over
and it's been a long two years it's been
a long two years but this does mark the
uh the midpoint
of the pandemic no don't
no no well it's it's looking like it
might be the end of the infectious part
of the pandemic and then the beginning
of the really annoying part
uh-oh
that is apparently not what you wanted
to hear i thought it was sort of an
uplifting message oh if there's light at
the end of the tunnel it just you need a
telescope to see it but
yeah yeah yeah
okay so um do you want to say anything
about where we're going before we get
into logistics so we just want to jump
into logistics
well
um
you know i mean yeah let's just say
we're going to talk a little bit about
the
very rapidly developing
story of where we find ourselves in the
pandemic we see mandates collapsing we
see marches occurring we see all sorts
of interesting stuff and uh that i think
tells us something about where we are
so we're going to discuss that we're
going to discuss why i will not be at
the march and i think that's
an important thread to have discussed um
so those things are are on the table i
know you have a couple of other things
you were planning to do indeed including
a couple of uh film recommendations for
films not brand new films but films that
we and with our boys watched this week
uh that we we recommend and um also
we're gonna finish i think with a little
bit about tiknot han who died today
and who whom we have spoken about
on the podcast in the past at one point
but first but first
uh we
are here on youtube and odyssey and um
excuse me and we we
this in the q a will also be on spotify
we are still trying to figure out our
video game obviously but uh this is
where we are
for now um you can ask your questions
for the q a at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
you can join either or both of our
patreons right now the question asking
period for the private monthly q a that
happens at my patreon is open it's a 48
hour window every month and it is always
open over the middle of the month
live stream and that's right now
so you can consider joining joining us
there those private q and as are a lot
of fun for us they are um they are small
enough that uh we keep the we can see
the chat and we can actually interact
with people um
which of course we don't do on these got
something to add well i wanted to uh no
doubt there are many people ducked up
going right now to see what it means
that we are still working on our video
game we are not working on a video game
we are working on our video
game we're trying to get dialed in as to
where we will be coming to you from
there's no there's no video game
happening certainly not a virtual
reality dark horse universe nothing like
that it's all pretty much as you
remember it one of the things that
happens when you have a really long two
years is the punctuation just goes out
the window yeah well the thing is for
for people substantially younger than us
they never believed in it just look at
their texts didn't believe in which
punctuation ah at all i thought you
meant either uh
the pandemic or the video game
well i'm not sure i think they sort of
hold all beliefs kind of lightly which
is probably wise in an era with uh so
much [ __ ] but um
yeah punctuation was never never on
their list of priorities
yeah who gives a talk about the oxford
comma and all that oh they definitely
don't as a whole generation the oxford
comma is i'm a fan frankly i like it
i i find i want i want to die for i
don't care that much but i like it it's
not a hilly time no definitely not nope
nope nope but i like it uh there are
times when it is actually clarifying and
therefore right i believe must be
used okay
um
you can find direwolves and epic dabbies
and digital book burning and such at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
on shirts and bags and i don't know what
else nothing much else shirts and bags
and blankets i guess
um you could join me um
almost all the content is free you can
sign up at my sub stack for
naturalselections.substance.com i wrote
about
sex differences in competition the first
of two parts this week the second part
is happening next week and there's going
to be some more covered content coming
coming up soon and then of course we
have um
has become our want uh three three
sponsors right at the top of the hour
here
and we start by saying how grateful we
are uh to those to those sponsors who
who are
here with us uh it is not an
insignificant thing uh to be supporting
us as we are
have been from nearly the beginning
speaking out against what we see as
uh mainstream narrative errors uh and uh
we are we are thankful for these three
sponsors
the first is vivo barefoot
most shoes are not made for your feet
they are made for someone's idea of what
feet should be and be constrained by an
issue that someone doesn't actually know
feet or what they can do vivo barefoot
in contrast nose feet they aren't driven
by fashion you can tell because the
shoes aren't really all that attractive
but man oh man are these shoes a
revelation we love these shoes they're
beyond comfortable the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fabulous our feet are the
products of millions of years of
evolution humans evolved to walk move
and run barefoot but modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases by 60 in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them
we keep running into people in the world
this continues to happen who comment on
the vivo barefoots we're wearing they're
wearing them too it's an odd little club
but growing once people start wearing
these shoes they don't seem to stop so
go to vivobarefoot.com
horse to get an exclusive offer of 20
off additionally all new customers get a
hundred day free trial so you can see if
you love them as much as we do that's v
i v o b a r e f o o t dot com slash dark
horse
our second sponsor for today is
m-o-i-n-k that's a
moo oink combination mike
they delivered grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught alaskan
salmon direct your door
just four companies control 80 percent
of the us meat industry and moic is
helping family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
something i hope that we can all get
behind
we had a turkey from mike for
thanksgiving
and excuse me
and another one for christmas actually
oh my god it was so so good and actually
just today i a couple days ago i made
soup and i just had a bowl of this soup
right now um that i made from the turkey
stock that we made from the turkey so
this this food just keeps on giving you
know this
gotta say
i i hope i'm not bragging too much here
but the soup is really really good it's
the turkey thank you turkey turkey the
turkey was excellent the soup has like
ginger and leeks and lemon and mint and
lots and lots of turkey stock
and it's fabulous we've had several
other steaks and lamb and bacon all
amazing everything we have tried is out
of this world it's so good i
particularly love the ribeye steak and
their sausages are amazing too
moist animals are raised outdoors the
fish swim wild in the ocean moink meat
is free of antibiotics hormone sugar and
all the other junk you find prepackaged
in the meat aisle i love everything
about mike the fact the meat is
grass-fed and finished on small farms
the lovely publications that come along
with it which remind me of what gourmet
magazine looked like in its heyday
before it went belly up and of course
the meat itself
was founded by an eighth generation
farmer
support mike support family farming so
join the mike movement today go to
mikebox.com darkhorse right now to get a
year of filet mignon for free then pick
what meats you want delivered with your
first box check what you get change what
you get each month and cancel any time
that's one year of the best filet mignon
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
spelled m o i n k
box dot com slash dark horse that's
mickbox.com
all right our third sponsor is md
hearing aid and uh i beg their
forgiveness and would remind them that
written english is not my first language
but i will
struggle my way through it
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
many of us even if we don't experience
hearing loss sometimes need to crank the
volume up on a show beyond what other
people need hearing loss is invisible to
those of us without it
md hearing aid is an fda-registered
rechargeable hearing aid that costs a
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost more than 80 percent less in fact
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but couldn't afford
them he made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford these hearing aids aim to fit so
well that no one will know you're
wearing them the rechargeable batteries
last up to 30 hours their volt plus is
their vote plus which is a branded
model is water resistant in up to three
feet of water and you don't need a
prescription for uh or a doctor's
appointment you buy it directly from the
source where audiologists and licensed
hearing specialists are available seven
days a week md hearing aid has knocked
the price down on hearing aids by
recognizing that about 95 of people who
need hearing aids only require a few
settings so they simplify the need for
certain components not needed by most
people and they cut out the middleman
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and this is what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech i wore the md
hearing aid to have a conversation with
a deep voiced man in a room with a lot
of white noise the md hearing aid passed
the test as my conversation partner's
voice was clear and understandable
at a price point
of under a thousand dollars i was amazed
at how effective they are
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing aids to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with a 100 money-back
guarantee
so get clinic level care for 80 less
with md hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to get there buy one
get one for three hundred dollars each
when you buy a pair deal plus
they are adding a free extra charging
case a hundred dollar value just for
listeners of darkhorse so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse or you can even call them at
1-833-772-1392
go to
mdhearingaid.com m-d-h-e-a-r-i-n-g
a-i-d dot com and use the promo code
darkhorse
all right
why don't
you start us off all right um i want to
explain why it is that i'm not going to
be in dc for the march on the 23rd which
is sunday
this was a difficult decision and one
i'm not entirely happy about i would
very much like to be there there are a
good number of people who have become
our friends over the last year who are
going to be present and
i feel like it would be a natural place
to be and i would love to speak to that
audience we actually have no idea how
many people are likely to go we know
that there are
quite a number of sign ups that if this
event looks like other events where
people have signed up in advance it
could be a million people on the other
hand somebody could be messing with the
march and they could be registering
large numbers
of phony names in order that we would
think more people are coming than
actually are but i suspect it's going to
be a large and successful event
however i was pretty concerned that
such a large fraction of the movement
the dissident doctors for example who
have told us so much during the pandemic
that we needed to understand about
things like vaccines things like
alternative treatments things like the
progression of coveton how you address
it such a large fraction of those
dissidents are going to be present that
i'm concerned that somebody who had been
embarrassed by these people might seek
to do something at the event which would
cast it in a false light or worse
and i thought it was necessary that
somebody stay outside somebody who had
seen the planning of the event so that
if somebody were to for example attempt
to make it look like a january sixth
insurrection or something like this
that there would be somebody able to say
actually i was there for the planning
here's what was said here's what the
intent was i don't know where that thing
came from but that wasn't what these
people were attempting to do
and so i have decided to stay home and
play that role as much as i would like
to be
present on the ground now i very much
hope to hear
that nothing has happened and in fact
maybe
i'm not the only person who has decided
to play the role of staying outside so
that we can speak to what has
actually taken place in the planning but
my hope is that if somebody did plan
something to embarrass uh the march or
worse that they will be dissuaded from
doing so by knowing that there are
people who will be able to speak very
clearly to what the planning of the
march looked like
in the aftermath
so anyway hopefully it goes off without
a hitch
and
we get to see
a
well i guess at the moment we're
watching mandates uh being withdrawn
around the world this march is uh
decidedly an anti-mandate march bringing
together uh people who are vaccinated
unvaccinated pro-vaccine anti-vaccine
bringing together people from both left
and right
because there's a great deal of
agreement that this
public health nightmare has been
radically mismanaged that the mandates
are not justified as we have said uh
here many times
they're not justified by this pathogen
they're not justified by these remedies
and they're not justified by the quality
of these public health authorities
um now which is to say just just to just
to repeat and we've repeated this many
times
um
there are there are some conditions
under which it is possible that a
mandate uh would be uh
would be something to consider but not
this pathogen not these vaccines not
with this government
yeah and i you know i will add to that
that it is hard to imagine um a
government uh sufficiently free of
corruption that it could be trusted with
this but what we're saying is that in
principle one could imagine a scenario
in which you had such a government and
you faced such a pathogen and you had
remedies that that justified and that
conclusion i think is one of the things
that maybe i shouldn't speak for you but
i think both of us i know i know myself
um
have woken up more too in the last
couple of years uh the the the the
recognition that much of the
conservative pushback to regulation
is precisely about the
[Music]
suspicion that it's actually impossible
uh to find a
government instantiation that is
trustworthy enough uh to to take it
forward yes now i was uh
i was thinking as i was biking home from
drop in toby at school yesterday
about the comparison just a thought
experiment that you know obviously one
can't know but i was thinking about the
comparison between bad news for you that
was today
really yeah wow okay you should start
over but just you know i'm just i'm
gonna just mess with your timeline but
i'm but i'm telling you the truth that
that was today okay well
yeah um i remember it like it was
yesterday
wow
okay sorry guys start over um
but anyway i was thinking about the
comparison between
the response to the pandemic that we saw
which was
almost
unbelievably top down
right we had we had
remote bureaucrats interfering with the
relationship between
your doctor and your pharmacist right
your doctor was not allowed to prescribe
certain things even though under normal
circumstances the doctor can prescribe
whatever they want right so that's an
amazing level of top-down coordination
that basically
you know rendered
doctors and pharmacists as automatons in
some system that had decided on one
one path let me say anecdotally that i
had a conversation with a doctor whom i
trust this week
uh no i trust this doctor all the time
but i had the conversation this week and
i was reporting
uh my experience with covet a couple
weeks ago and reported that i had gotten
a prescription for
uh hcq
and uh and this doctor whom i trust said
how did that prescription go through
i can't get it through i cannot get the
prescription put through and i'm
i think i'm not going to explain it here
because i think it's probably not safe
to do so and that further tells you what
kind of a landscape we're living in
but the idea that a doctor should be
asking a patient uh that you know how
how is it that some other doctor was
able to prescribe something completely
legitimately
uh when this has always been the prayer
view of doctors this is you know the
this is one of the things you go to
school for is to gain some autonomy to
to have this sort of you know this stamp
of approval on your forehead that says
you now know enough
that we are going to vouch for the fact
that you are going to make decisions and
sometimes those decisions will harm
people and overall they will do people
good and you are able to make those
decisions for yourself and this
incredibly top-down top-down and just
remarkably like across the board
authoritarian response
took
took the power away from all of the
people who who have earned it and that
includes also of course the individuals
who don't have medical degrees who
wanted to be able to say um continue to
take supplements that they had been
taking before the the kinds of
supplements like nac that were yanked
from shelves
right um and you know what i what i
concluded is that i believe if doctors
had been left to their own devices right
if there had been no overarching uh
public health mandates of any kind at
any level and doctors had done what
doctors are trained to do which is to
treat patients that have
diseases that they can't be certain of
the nature of and to discover what works
right
doctors try things they try things based
on the fact that this set of symptoms
implies that this system is doing that
thing and these
uh you know drugs tend to be helpful in
those cases
doctors would do that they would
discover i mean as we discovered
you know ventilators seemed like the
thing right they weren't right doctors
figured that out but
the the point is you would
expect a
crude initial response to get rapidly
better on the fa on the basis that
doctors are intelligent people who can
talk to each other pool information and
get smarter collectively rather than
have some thing in washington with
unknown allegiances dictating a response
and handing it down and then brow
beating
and penalizing doctors for departing
from it which is what we saw and i think
to my way of thinking it is essentially
certain that we would have lost fewer
people and we would have had a lot less
carnage
if doctors had been left to do the thing
that they
are in general left to do which is
access the pharmacopoeia among other
things and figure out what works and
presumably
uh be free
to put out their recommendations which
has has been noted for for many many
months many many times now it is
remarkable that there are almost no sets
of recommendations for either
prophylaxis or treatment for this
disease that's insane that is insane
there is a set
of um
stamped with the approval of of the
government and the pharmaceutical
companies
vaccines so-called and there are a
couple of newly generated
again by the pharmaceutical companies
drugs and
nothing else is officially approved and
that's
there's never been a pathogen in the
history of the earth for which nothing
else that isn't brand new has worked
and even even though it is quite clear
at this point that this pathogen um was
helped in its evolution with with humans
that doesn't make it such a new thing
that it can only be treated with things
that have been created by humans
yeah um
there's
there's no possibility that you wouldn't
find useful things to do doctors around
the world have come up with different
protocols we've got a bunch of them that
work and the point is you also have a
public health apparatus swearing that
they don't wear work swearing that the
doctors who put these are out are
yeah cranks and that's just
um abnormal and frankly transparent
right there is some other priority here
right that involves disrupting normal
medicine and you know
basically uh setting a precedent for uh
basically allowing your government to
stand in for your doctor
yeah which is appalling so anyway
um good luck to the dissidents who are
speaking at this march this weekend i
really hope it is a smashing success
that a huge number of people show up
that everyone is well behaved that
anything that is planned to embarrass or
disrupt the march is called off and that
the worst we face are
a lot of really terrible people shouting
anti-vaxx which is what they're already
doing right you know which is a crazy
thing you know
we're talking about people many of whom
have been vaccinated right we're talking
about vaccine-injured people right right
it's it's a it's appalling but i think
by now pretty much everybody will you
still function
to reject that stigma those who have
been injured by a thing do become
somewhat opposed to the thing under many
circumstances they might but the point
is to say anti-vex is to imply that this
is somehow an ideological position
rather than yes the evidence tells
people who have been injured by
something that it is perhaps not so safe
well that's and that's part of what it
is actually and that's part of what i
think is driving both you and me so
crazy at the moment which is that um
on the other side the people who are
yelling anti-vags just like the people
who were yelling racist four and five
and six years ago are in fact ideologues
and they may have dressed up like
scientists and like humanists and like
thinkers and like intellectuals but that
doesn't make it so what they are is
ideologues and they've got a conclusion
and they're going to stick to it no
matter what else happens
and because they are ideologues and they
know that that is the basis by which
they make decisions they assume that
everyone else that they encounter is as
well they're like yeah yeah i know you
claim you're a scientist but so am i
right hahaha i also have a conclusion
and we just have come to different
conclusions so we're going to argue
about it it's like you know what
we're not all ideologues
and
what is happening right now the
narrative is is crumbling right
and you begin to see some of frankly the
ideologues
backpedaling
and some of the backpedaling is going to
convince some of the people
and some of the people who would have
been very happy to see
us and the others like us who have been
vocal and
and out there from you know from from
the beginning um disappeared into the
abyss and in fact tried to help that
happen
some of them are going to be the ones
who are positioned to win in the new
world order well that's the the next
thing i want to talk about is um
the scramble that is about to unfold
which i think frankly most of the people
who have been paying attention to
the better more predictive
dissident narrative about public health
and covid
are having the sense of okay well
omicron swept in and it took the
pandemic out of the public health
tyrant's hands right it effectively
handed us something that couldn't be
controlled and wasn't killing very many
people and that has brought us to a
place that feels like it could be the
end of the pandemic
now i will say
some people who are well positioned to
think about these things
have warned about what might emerge next
i don't yet know what to think about
that but let's just say
assuming that we do not have a next
variant that kicks this into some other
phase that we haven't yet thought about
right this does look like well
probably the end of something because so
many people are getting this
vaccinated and not vaccinated that at
some level to the extent that natural
immunity is
a decisive factor right we're going to
reach herd immunity quickly because
it's racing through the population
so with that said the point is all right
mandates are coming down because people
can see that mandates don't really make
any sense right what are you mandating
you're mandating a vaccine that doesn't
prevent people from contracting the
disease doesn't prevent them from
transmitting it doesn't reduce
viral load on what basis are you doing
that and they will say well because it
reduces hospitalizations well even if
that's true for young healthy people
that is no reason to mandate right are
you protecting me from me by locking me
in my house and firing me from my job
that doesn't seem like it's very likely
to actually be coherent right i also i'm
i'm kind of not feeling protected here
right maybe right so the point is the
the absurdity of the mandates and the
and you know really what it what has
happened
is that omicron has revealed what we
have been saying all along which is that
something else is driving this right
they swear it's being driven by a desire
to protect civilization and the point is
at the point that makes no sense they
still want to do it but
they still want to do it and um i know
you're going somewhere but i think this
is a good place to just show this um
i i
i saw this on twitter today zach if you
would show it nobody said you wouldn't
get covered if you're vaccinated we keep
on being told like just you know
constant constant gaslighting by these
people
uh and so uh this this woman has um put
together just a few places where of
course they said that you wouldn't get
covered if you're vaccinated here we
have from joe biden on july 21st of last
year on cnn you're not going to get
coveted if you have these vaccinations
from wallenski the director of the cdc
on march 29th on msnbc of last year
vaccinated people do not carry the virus
don't get sick
fauci the niaid director on may 17th of
last year msnbc when people are
vaccinated they can feel safe they will
not be infected
and fauci again
of the vaccines on may 17th again last
year they're really really good against
variants
all of these things are untrue
some of these things were lies
right um i'm not going to claim that
biden was lying but he just didn't know
but my god you know we and and we we
keep they keep on
changing what it is they're claiming
that they already said to us and if we
can't even keep track of that then of
course they're going to continue to win
and of course they're going to erect the
new people
who they can claim okay yeah well we got
this wrong and we'll have a couple of
fall guys like well you know we'll we'll
make sure a couple of people have their
heads sort of metaphorically cut off and
um and prop up some new people in the
positions that already existed with the
systems that already existed with all
the same incentives that already existed
you you got to slow down through that
because people are not going to
understand what's what's about to happen
here's the problem you've got
public health elites and whatever it is
that they represent
they have screwed up at uh an
unprecedented level they've effectively
crashed many of the functional systems
of planet earth they've caused untold
misery and frankly
untold disease i would suggest people
take a look at
john campbell's video from this week
talking about how many people actually
died of covet it's quite eye-opening
but he also talks about what people did
die of things like you know delays in
cancer diagnoses and things like this so
the point is this is an
unprecedented catastrophe
and the natural outgrowth of an
unprecedented catastrophe is a kind of
collective soul searching in which we
figure out who screwed up
how it happened what system should have
been in place so it doesn't happen again
and we move forward in that way
but
were that to happen these incredibly
powerful many cases now incredibly
wealthy elites who earned so much
through this
colossal error those people have
everything to lose if we actually figure
out what happened and install the
systems that would prevent it from ever
happening again
so they're now in search
of anything that can save them from
facing the people who were right
right
now what that means is that there's a
race that is going to be kicking off
here and we're already seeing the first
signs of it and the race is for people
who weren't right all along who are now
going to
challenge the public health authority
right they're going to point out just
how disastrous so brave it's very brave
they're going to say
these public health officials failed us
but
and then they're going to attack those
of us who had this stuff right and the
idea is that the elites have an
incentive now to embrace this new middle
ground that is neither fish nor foul
right it is not on board with the public
health narrative it challenges it in
very strong terms but it also challenges
the dissidents who will be accused of
all sorts of defects and the point is
the elites have an interest in finding
that voice the struggle to phrase it
just so is now on and so people will be
falling all over themselves they will
some of them will know what they're
doing they're they're jockeying for
position in the new world order some of
them will not know what they're doing
they will just detect that suddenly
they're seeing articles on on a
particular theme in all sorts of places
and they will think i could write that
article and they will write it and so
you'll have this whole new group of
people in the middle and their purpose
their purpose is to prevent meaningful
change right no no that is the utility
that's not why they exist they are
taking advantage of an empty niche and
they will be adopted by um the the
mainstream and the elite in order to
serve the purpose of the elite right
well
let's just say the purpose of the niche
is that is to protect the elite from uh
a reckoning in light of what they have
done to yeah this is reckoning insurance
it's reckoning insurance but here's the
other thing there's another dimension to
this yeah which is that are there a huge
number of people in the audience who
aren't going to write that article
they're not going to write any article
but they're in a bad position right
because to the extent that for a year
you've been brow beating people for
being on the wrong side of history and
then it turns out they were on the right
side of history closer to two
well let's just say there are people who
go back two years but we've been we've
been hearing these voices and the point
is if you're somebody who's been on the
wrong side of this and you were sure you
were on the right side of this and
you've been chastising people publicly
you've been shunning your friends and
all then the point is now you're in a
very awkward position that actually
mirrors the position of the elites who
want to stay in power right and so the
point is you've got a bunch of people
who will hunt for the best phrasing of
this narrative so that they can uh be uh
pulled up into the positions of power
that will decide what will be done and
what will be done is symbolic [ __ ] and
nothing more
right you've got an audience in search
of an excuse which is to say yes the
public health authorities did fail us
but those other people weren't right
right and you know you've got the elites
and their point is look anything so long
as it doesn't take us out of our
positions of power right that confluence
of those three is going to result in a
scramble that you're not going to see
coming and it's going to result in the
promise of reform and there will be no
reform and if you don't know what i'm
talking about
i would suggest you go watch the
excellent film
the big short
you want not one of the films i'm going
to recommend later but yes the big short
is a is a third film
it's a beautiful and heartbreaking film
and pay very close attention to the end
right this is this is coming and we
could get in the road we could prevent
this but we have to be very careful
because the temptation to embrace these
people who have been outside of the fray
and are now going to rush in and they're
going to shout at the right people and
they're going to shout at the wrong
people and they're going to seem like
they're somehow more moderate and it's
nonsense it's strategic right
the people that you should be talking to
are people who took a risk and said what
needed to be said even when it was
almost impossible to do so
and
generated predictions based on an actual
understanding of the situation by
deriving
uh
deriving meaning from what we could see
from first principles as much as
possible i think frankly much of what
much of what i'm wrestling with at the
moment is is god i mean as i told you
like there's a sadness that sort of
verges into rage
um
and i've just got this deep
disappointment with a lot of people who
i thought were honorable
and brave
and insightful and full of wisdom
and
um
this has gone on long enough
and they have been
so many people have been
unwilling or incapable and it is often
hard to determine which it is
to actually investigate the evidence in
front of them and generate
a claim or an opinion that runs in any
way counter until like until yesterday
right like until the last couple of
weeks in the last month you know like
just about a year ago is when we saw the
loudly crumble in exactly this way like
this is just about a year out from the
loudly narrative crumbling this way and
suddenly there were a lot of people
going yeah but i was saying so i was
saying so
and
now that's just like this dull roar and
you know some fouchy and you know
barrack and all and dasic are still
denying it but it's it's you can say
that now without risking getting uh
kicked off youtube for instance um but
you still you can't you know we're we're
still demonetized we're still at risk
for talking about all the rest of the
things we're talking about and the
people whom
i thought of as honorable and brave and
insightful and full of wisdom
who have said
nothing that counters the mainstream
narrative until like yesterday or not
even yet
and who are going to somehow contort
themselves into positions that make them
appear to have been carefully thinking
it through all along
when what has been revealed is actually
the
the white-coated scientism thing
has confused most people who actually
don't understand what science is most
people who actually have never thought
of themselves as scientists or done
science or engaged with people really
truthfully honestly with the people who
are doing science
really have no idea and so they they
really feel like they have no ability to
assess the claims and so we have a whole
lot of people who have been claiming to
assess the claims who are actually doing
no such thing and so now the narrative
is crumbling and they're going to jump
up on top of that smoldering pile and
say aha yes here i am here i am like
what even are you standing on like
they're still going to be unable to
assess the claims that they're that
they're either now
saying
yes or true or no they aren't because
they've revealed throughout this that
again they're either unwilling or
incapable of doing so well
we're going to have to
do a better job of sorting because
they're going to be very various
different categories of people
well
i would say that there are certain
heuristics right it is now going to
become
profitable to find that middle ground
position of course so you don't know
anybody who adopts it now why they're
adopting it right you do not have
evidence that they have you know if if
you get slightly ahead of the narrative
now but it ends up being a huge win then
the point is okay well what is that
right i think that was you promoting
yourself i don't think that was you
actually you know figuring it out so the
question is what is this on the other
hand the scales will fall from people's
eyes more and more rapidly right right
and so
it's
a very different realm but i found uh i
adopted a policy
um
for people who came to me this happened
somewhat regularly and people came to me
after uh the evergreen thing
and apologized right
and they said you know what i gotta tell
you i did not know what was going on i
called it backwards and i'm so
embarrassed and i would say
you know what
you don't owe me an apology and here's
why
when you figured it out you did the
right thing right anybody who does the
right thing upon discovering what it
actually is
we're square and i think we need to
adopt this policy generally but the
right thing
includes
not pretending that you always felt this
way
or that you were really on the side and
you you like i'm gonna dig up something
that i said or wrote or tweeted you know
once six months ago in a sea of things
like
no that's not the right thing that's
cheating and you know it you know it
right so
you've got a being honest about the fact
that you've changed your position is
fundamental right doing the right thing
and the right thing does not mean just
wagging your finger at the people who
screwed this up so badly it means not
wagging your finger at the people who
got it right right
that's that's also part of the right
thing 100 fundamental yeah um
and you know then the question is
and this is the tough part i think we
need to figure out
how to feel
about the various different categories
of people right
so i don't want to get too far in the
weeds here but obviously feeling
is
a
proxy for stuff right we feel because
it's a quick way of actually deploying a
you know game theoretic approach that
has been refined by selection and it's
not very
properly applied to many modern
circumstances so for example
if you imagine yourself
a thousand years ago
in some circumstance where some person
delivers you a terrible insult if you're
a man let's say and some person delivers
you a no
we're clear on that but um
if somebody delivers you a terrible
insult suggesting that you are you know
a weak person
it might be important that you throw a
punch
because if you don't it might imply that
the person was actually accurate and it
might result in you facing a lot of uh
bad stuff going forward on the other
hand in modern times if you're
in a bar
500 miles from home and some person that
you've never seen and will never see
again says something insulting the game
theory is very different but you still
have the same emotional reaction so i
mean this is this is fascinating i
didn't expect us to go here um
the piece i'm working on for the second
part of this competition as it differs
between the sexes uh for my substance
for next week is based on uh an invited
commentary that um
that i just wrote that i just was just
published a week and a half ago or so in
the in the journal in the scientific
journal the archives of sexual behavior
and it's specifically it's called
something like covert versus overt um
on the different competitive styles
of of women and men
and you know the idea is in part uh
precisely this that um
male-style competition so dominance
hierarchies exist
in i think
certainly all species that could be said
to have friendships and i think pretty
much all species that are social
but um the the way that humans are so
unique one of the many ways that that we
are unique is that we not only we have
um hierarchies in both sexes and
actually i've only been able to find
chakma baboons that also have male
hierarchies and female hierarchies most
species of primates and elephants and
stuff have a dominance hierarchy in one
sex but not in the other
but then in modernity we bring it
together and you know we act like oh we
can just you know work together and play
together and everything men and women
together as if um as if the different
hierarchical styles the different rules
by which we create and maintain
social interactions with one another
aren't different
and as if they will just slide together
easily without ever negotiating and of
course of course that's not going to be
the case and
men for reasons that i won't get into
here but do get into and this piece will
be published on tuesday um are much more
likely to
um to say hey man you don't take it
outside like what was that
and
like it's on right now here now we're
doing this and it is um
it has hard borders in space and time
it's direct it's for an audience it's
there right and female style competition
is much more likely to be covert to
happen away from an audience to happen
in fact when a person is alone but
engaging in a competition that over in
ecology speak you might call like
scramble competition for instance
and um that
doesn't look like what we think of as
competition and so we have all this
research claiming that while women
aren't really that competitive women say
they're not competitive so they're not
competitive or [ __ ] right like this
is not true at all it just looks
different and what we see
in so much of especially 21st century
version weird modernity is basically
female style dominance hierarchy tactics
being adopted by everyone and everyone
pretending that well if it's not overt
male style dominance interactions well
then it's not competitive at all and
you're probably imagining it and that's
the basis of a lot of the gaslighting
right like oh you're imagining it like
no i'm not that's for real and we all
know it and frankly if it looked like
you know if it looked like teenage girls
then we'd see it but because it's
so-called adults doing things that
really you should have grown out of it
if you were a dude you never should have
been doing it in the first place then we
don't see it
all right um so let's look at some of
the
modern
um
proxy emotion landscape and figure out
how it's suppose what we are supposed to
be feeling at this moment and compare it
to how we are actually feeling in this
moment yeah
um so let's take something like uh the
desire for vengeance
okay the desire for vengeance i'm going
to argue is
rather like
panic i'm going to argue that panic is
almost never a good idea under modern
circumstances right you are almost
always better off being level-headed
which doesn't mean that panic is never
adaptive it was adaptive that's why it
exists but the point is modern
circumstances are much more likely to
require you to puzzle through something
than they are going to benefit from you
flailing about and you know right that
flailing is
usually not the right response no and it
can it can get you drowned it can do all
kinds of things and so the basic point
is hey if you could actually turn off
panic yeah there's probably occasional
circumstances in which that would be bad
but it's sort of like a seatbelt you're
just kind of better off with it off you
know yeah i'm gonna argue vengeance is a
bit like this
vengeance
before we had things like governance and
hearings was an essential mechanism
right and what it is actually is a
version of uh i'm using this term
technically spite right spite
as you well know is defined as accepting
a cost in order to deliver a cost all
right i'm going to accept harm to me in
order to deliver harm to you why would
anyone ever do that well it's necessary
because if you betray me and i don't
deliver you a cost then betraying me
becomes cheap so if i want to be
betrayed less i deliver a cost so that
it isn't cheap and that causes the
system to to work better but if you have
a long-term win um
in the aggregate or else you would we
wouldn't have spite existing at all
right right so spite you know you and
just for those of you who are
scratching your head as to what the hell
we're talking about so policing is
actually integral it is a spite
mechanism right we as a society pay a
price to hire police to make sure that
if you commit a crime that is bad for
society you pay a cost right so police
and prisons population level spike yeah
huh hmm okay i'm gonna um
i i see i see what you mean there i
think it's gonna be taken out of context
and you're gonna be accused of it being
one of those a cab guys or something
which of course you're not
um
no no i'm saying it you know the point
is it it's the cheapest way to
accomplish something important the last
thing you want is everybody having to
take you know
vengeance into their own hands in order
to ensure that civilization works then
there's a whole lot more carnage that
way rather than why don't we all agree
to offload our vengeance instinct to a
force that we can then regulate with
rules that say what it is and isn't
allowed to do and you know
it's just better right
you know the monopoly on violence is the
better less violent way of dealing with
it than having everybody have to you
know engage in their own violence
okay so the point is
there is a sense of like
i have watched these people
crash
a planet i have become very fond of
right yeah
and
i have watched
utter indifference to the suffering of
human beings a willingness to keep
useful medicines away from people who
desperately need them right even though
that resulted in people's deaths and
that means there were families grieving
who didn't need to right the keeping
useful medicines away is particularly
galling right
um
the destruction of children the
destruction of children the indifference
the the um
feigned uh
inability to understand the
developmental impact of you know
shielding the face with the mask that is
not especially effective to protect them
from a disease that isn't especially
dangerous i know you're on a roll here
but can i just show
um
gosh
i had it cued up and now it's gone
um
okay so this uh zach this was in next
door um yesterday or today
for somewhere our region of portland
school parents today uh the oregon
health authority held a public comment
hearing on making mask mandates
permanent there were over 335 people on
the call and 125 plus people spoken
lasted for over six hours not one person
spoke for the rule oha heard the plea
now it's time for your school boards to
hear it start emailing your schools to
demand that they make masking a choice
for parents and stop dehumanizing our
children
to which one of the responses was oh wow
that's tiny
keith wearing a mask dehumanizes a child
about as much as them wearing socks or
eating a burrito
i i get his point with respect to the
socks but a burrito
it's not even [ __ ] funny man i'm
sorry no it's real like i'm sorry but
it's not funny like these people
are
doing so much damage to children and
we spend a lot of time talking about
childhood in our book in the hunter
gatherers guide to the 21st century and
it is
and we've we've done it a lot on this on
the show but
how you could be an adult on this planet
and actually really believe
that covering a child's face
for
most of their waking hours in school
which is given how bad school is now
mostly about social interactions and not
about learning anyway
that that could not be having an effect
that cannot be dehumanizing children how
either this guy is a is a troll and does
not believe this which i hope
but given
the back and forth that then ensues i
don't think so
people actually believe this i know
people actually believe that children
having been masked in some places for
a year and a half an academic year and a
half
is fine
it's fine
right no it's it's incredibly not fine
the question is okay it's happened a
huge amount of damage has been done to
a generation of children
um
it won't be undone
there may be things that we can do to
reduce the damage but it won't be undone
it's a permanent fact of the way this
was approached and on a future podcast
i'd like to talk about what actually
happened and why right i think we can
infer a great deal about what the
pandemic actually was
you know of course it it was a pandemic
there is a pathogen but it was something
else too there is a pathogen that
doesn't mean there was a pandemic
well i don't know you know i'm not
saying there wasn't a pandemic but there
is a pathogen
therefore there was a pandemic is not a
logical
uh necessity what i have said is that we
had a wave of tyranny riding on covet
yes that it used covid to do other
things and the other things are
something that we need to become rapidly
aware of because the fact is this is the
kind of excuse that can spring out of
nowhere it can spring out of a lab in
some place that you don't know anything
about and you know suddenly you're
dealing with a global phenomenon whether
you like it or not far less likely to
spring out of a cave that you know i
think about right right for reason you
know they pulled that one over on us and
they
claimed and many people believed that
actually this sort of thing was ready to
happen any day of the week
you know as i argued in my unheard piece
earlier in the year actually that's not
right it's much harder for something to
leap out of a cave than you think and
this [ __ ] that people like dasic
like to say about you know oh the you
know the expansion of the human
population is putting humans in contact
with wildlife more and more right like
that sounds really logical it's just
[ __ ] right
it's [ __ ] for simple easy to
understand ecological reasons and no
this wasn't threatening to happen any
day of the week they created they you
know they created the exact
they brought forth the golem right and
then
required us to bend to their will in
order to address it and anyway you know
and also i mean you just like you know
he's not an idiot and he is training as
a zoologist so he knows damn well it's
not true
right yeah
you know whatever the explanation i mean
let's say we just need to get to the
bottom of it but i want to go back to
the question about about vengeance okay
so we have a built-in because you're a
better person than i am in this regard
you can tell that i i am i am
having a hard time
but not better person that's not what's
going on
um you are you know the language i was
using with you earlier is um you are you
are better able to find you know this is
weird language for us but uh you're a
bit able to find your christian self
you're better able to find your
forgiveness
well at the moment okay but let's take
the christian self uh
way of describing it right i would argue
that the christian thing right the thing
you're referring to
is actually a kind of enlightenment that
has to do
you know it's not inherently christian
but the place that it is inscribed for
you know the european derived west is
you know in in those
particular
narratives but but the point is
you go from
little tiny bands of closely related
people who are aligned by genes
and you start benefiting from
collaborating with people who are less
and less related to you and it's
actually so much better that you need
new stories to explain why you're doing
it and why you're ignoring relatedness
right and so you're sort of moving in
this direction okay right and you know
it's compensating for two things one
keeping less and less close track of
whether or not you're closely related
and right um and the point is it's so
huge whether or not you know did you did
you raise his barn last week or was that
someone else's book right it becomes
indirect and the point is i'm going to
participate in this thing that raises
barns when they need to be raised right
and i'm not going to hold back right so
anyway
if we can just
put in a
final piece on your claim of betterness
i do believe that in this particular
regard only i'm actually benefiting from
a kind of enlightenment that has to do
with just staring at that game theory
over and over again and then it actually
changes how you feel once you realize
you know once you realize panic is no
good
you can learn not to do it right this is
that same thing and so anyway what i
will argue
is that vengeance the urge to see those
people suffer
a you will immediately have less of a
taste for it when you realize where you
heard it last
right
um but
the urge to see people suffer is
different from
not feeling forgiving and is different
from and you know something that i have
explicitly called for i think here
before which is a reckoning in which all
of those people
actually face themselves in the mirror
oh that's the idea look at yourself and
be
honest
and
frankly
at the point that you proclaimed to all
of the rest of us
that you were always this the other it
will be clear if you are actually have
actually been honest with yourself or
not
and all too often there has been no
reckoning right but here's the question
um
what is more like i agree with you the
ideal thing is for people to go be
honest with themselves because then what
comes out of it is not a defensive
reaction in which they forget what they
believe right it's an upgrade and if
they say ah
where did i go wrong
i don't want to do that again so what
was i really sure of and how did i end
up sure of it and then what should it
where was my first indication that i had
it wrong you know where's the first
signpost i missed because if they don't
do that and we do come out of this now
the narrative collapses and you know
this north northern hemisphere summer
actually feels like the summer of 2019
what happens in three years
right when the next whatever it is
happens well that's why these people
will not have learned and it will be
worse and faster not only these people
will not have learned the people that we
actually know and interact with but the
elites who did this cynically those
people will still be in a position
well and you know it look
let's take a let's take a parallel uh
example
the financial collapse of 2008 was about
a housing bubble
but the point is there's a game which i
have called the bubble game which just
requires you to declare some place for a
bubble so that you can get people in you
know
bubble frenzy you can profit on the way
up and leave them with the thing when it
blows up and the point is dealing with
the housing bubble by focusing on
housing is a mistake you need to focus
on the culture of
profiting through bubbles right yes
that's the thing to focus on and so in
this case we had a particular pandemic
and what we need is for a general
recognition that this was a
massive exercise in rent seeking right
that we have just all been dragged along
kicking and screaming in a massive
exercise of rent seeking that actually
shifted it transferred a huge amount of
well-being right
recognizing what that was and not
leaving those people in a position to do
it again is fundamental but
here's what we need to
figure out
how should you feel
about
you know
the prime movers
right like i'm not in a forgiving mood
and i don't think that the ultimate
prime movers were actually
um
engaged in a noble activity that turned
out
to be an error right there are too many
indications that that's not what
happened
that said personally i don't feel any
need for you know
for vengeance what i feel a need for is
a complete airing of what happened and
that such people for example fauci needs
to never ever again be in a position of
power over anything important right
and how do we get there what is that
what what are the chances that there's
going to be a complete airing no
that's not going to happen well but you
know that should happen people
people need to understand what the
scramble that's coming is about and the
point is the scramble whether or not we
have anything like a complete airing is
going to depend on whether or not the
people in the middle who are going to
scold both sides are allowed to get away
with that move that cynical move is
going to make it impossible to get to
the bottom of what happened right it's
going to ensure that we have an outcome
like the end of the big short reveals
from the housing crisis
so
all i'm arguing is that we need to kind
of up our game and we need to recognize
who we all of us
those of us who are feeling like okay
the narrative is finally collapsing and
people are beginning to wake up in large
numbers to things that we've been trying
to tell them for a very long time so up
our game how to what end what
a
um
whatever the mechanism is we need people
to understand that it is in their own
interest to figure out what happened and
figure out what role they played in it
and get to the right side of it as quick
as possible right the rationalizing is
what's going to do us in the next time
if we rationalize this time it's going
to cause it to happen again so we want
people
and you know the problem is that that
actually involves
but that does require a reckoning right
that does require looking at yourself
and saying yeah actually
three months ago i was in a different
place yeah but
but in order to get people to do that
they need to know that
there's a hug on the other side of it
that if you do that frightening exercise
that you can come back
right and so that's the point about
the desire
there are bad people right and the
reason that we punish bad people is so
that others will not do what they did
right or that they won't do it again
right but ultimately what we need it you
know truth and reconciliation is a
process invented to take this situation
and say look if we play the game out
right if we go after you and try to
punish you for what you did
then
you will resist and you will probably
win and we'll never even find out what
it was and we need to know what it was
in order to prevent it from happening so
we will trade you
something like amnesty
for honesty right that's a good trade
believe it or not
and we need to figure out what that
looks like here right in order that we
can get to the bottom of this because
the the bottom of this is pretty pretty
ugly
right we need to know what happened well
i think you're talking about two
different levels and i think the level
at which i am most um
sort of tormented at the moment is not
at the level of uh the people who are
actually driving policy in any way but
the people who
were helping facilitate the public
messaging
um
through you know media and social media
presence
and uh
those people are capable of being very
squidgy about what it is that they're
claiming now and then and before and in
the future and the sort of weaseling out
of things and it's the
it's the for it's the seeing into the
very near future seeing the weaseling
and the um
and the requests for hugs
well i was like i'm
[ __ ] hugging you well stop being a
weasel no you need to stop being a
weasel first well right but but the
point is
it's like one of these things like
quitting smoking
right people don't quit smoking because
it's very hard right but they don't make
eye contact with the fact that the
hardness of it is not an argument
against quitting it's an argument for
quitting now because it gets worse
right so
the game theory has to work out such
that people face something that they
would not otherwise be willing to face
in order that they get to the other side
and the point is look
and and you know look this is also
written into
um
religious doctrine right there's a
reason that confession functions the way
it does and the point is you don't want
to create a situation where somebody is
just damned because that's a very
dangerous person we want to create a
situation where somebody has a route
back
and that makes them behave better in the
future and this is that
and
anyway i mean you know
let's put it this way most people
did not do the worst there were some
terrible
terrible people who did absolutely
jaw-droppingly awful things
then there were a lot of useful idiots
who got taken advantage of so useful
right so much utility out there
they became very useful and they became
very dangerous but the point is what
crime is that right
it's a serious crime if you don't learn
that you were used as a tool against
other people who didn't deserve to have
you wielded against them yeah right and
so the point is you want the useful
idiots to become immune to useful idiocy
in the in the future
right and that does involve being ready
to recognize that they didn't mean to do
it
right yep um
doesn't mean they shouldn't have known
better but
yeah i mean i guess
i guess i am i'm stuck
in part because i'm stuck but also in
part because i see precisely i'm you
know
we're not going to talk about any names
but i'm thinking about a couple of
people in particular
who i can already see repositioning
themselves so as to appear to be doing
what you're talking about
but are
making their plays in various ways so
that they will socially advance from
this
and
that is already driving me crazy and it
is illegitimate and calling it out you
know i
i could start to call it out by name but
that's not i don't think that that would
help
um and it is
it is
[Music]
same old same old you know it is it just
and yet the stakes this time have been
so
high so many people have had their lives
destroyed so many children have been
permanently damaged
more people died than needed to die
more economies died than needed to die
and there are a lot of people who are
going to make social gains because that
is the game they were playing the whole
time yep oh and that is what they care
about
and that that
gets me anybody who plays this
strategically at this point
is a problematic person yeah okay right
we've been through hell and i mean we as
a species have been through hell over
this right and for you to play it
strategically at this point especially
if you're going to go after people who
were more right than you were
it's unacceptable i'm not defending that
at all right the scramble is not what
i'm talking about i'm talking about the
vast sea of people who have no position
in the scramble right they're just
trying to figure out what to think about
where they were and what they've just
learned yeah so there's like there's at
least three different
categories that we're talking about here
and you know
the the people who have no particular
ability to make social strides
um from coming to grips with where
they've been and what this means about
the future by all means yeah you know
yes yes forgiveness and and and
let us you know let us join hands and
move into the future together and never
do this again yeah so i will just say um
there's a particular person who i'm not
going to mention here um somebody well
known who did approach me uh
years after the evergreen meltdown and
did say hey look i do owe you an apology
and he explained what he had thought
and this is somebody that i am now
extra fond of even though i would say he
did he did
well but not brilliantly uh in the
public health crisis here right he made
some bad calls but the point is i know
but he was honest
i know what he will do upon discovery
that he [ __ ] up right and the point is
that is such a useful and important
piece of information because it's not a
window into
you know
what takes place it's a window into
values and what we're really trying to
deal with here is the fact that people's
values were utilized to turn them into
useful idiots etc
and that what you need to know is that
look if somebody knows
if you if the
the facts of a situation are clear
enough that somebody will do the right
thing rather than
figuring out which way the wind blows
and then figuring out what to do about
the facts which is there's far too much
of that yeah that's right
um
a couple things that are sort of
of
of what we're talking about um
i just like the follow-up to this tweet
so much that i want to share this uh if
i can don't show it yet zach it looks
like i don't oh here we go
um
oh
it's evening
um boy where did i put flux there it is
no no
there we go yeah
okay
okay yep that's fine okay um
just heard intel has dropped oregon
employee vaccine mandate they are the
largest private employer in oregon now i
went looking and i can't actually find
confirmation of this but i did find a
lot of stuff from intel
um
even in december and even in january
saying yep if you're not if you don't
meet our deadline by january by april
you're on leave without pay yada yada
yada and it seems like intel is backing
off this like so many
uh both private companies and and
governments um but this response
is so good they followed the science so
hard
[Laughter]
glad to see these reversals not so
pleased to see it without some heads
rolling people's livelihoods were
destroyed and all they can say now is
oops we were just following orders
so a that is consistent with how i've
sort of been feeling but um
they follow the science so hard yeah
it's it's such a hilarious way of
framing it yeah it's a it's a really
good good phrasing of it yeah so i don't
know i mean i i don't feel like we're
done and i don't feel like we're in a
position to even sum up what it was
we've said but i do think that we need
uh
we need some tools for this and the
tools have to involve
openness for what anybody involved at
any level has to say
but you know
a
a recognition that there's
a lot of places that people will go that
are not
born of um you know a desire to do the
right thing they're born of a desire to
find a safe place to stand even if
you've made the world much more unsafe
for other people who actually were
trying to tell you something that you
needed to know yeah right and that's the
thing that's really so troubling people
who tried to tell you things you need to
know were demonized and if you were if
you participated or if you were you know
too credulous and you accepted that
these people were bad grifters whatever
it is that was said about them right you
need to do some soul searching period
and
yeah you do it and we're square as far
as i'm concerned you don't do it and you
know that's that's on you that's that's
a that's a defect of of
of your person and it's not a small one
i guess but it's also true though isn't
it that um
there's got to be a statute of
limitations
well there's a de facto statute of
limitations but the problem is
you know when evergreen happened we said
one of the
most important lessons was that you
don't really know
about the qualities of the people you're
interacting with until you have a crisis
that reveals what they will actually do
right and so we have that same situation
here we know it's so much the same and
i know how long it took for me to get to
a place of going like okay well i'm glad
i know wow a lot of people disappointed
me but i'm glad i know i'm having a at
the moment i know i'm having a hard time
being glad i know yeah but but here's
the thing you know how we sometimes get
letters from people that we never met
who say
yeah oh and evergreen specifically i was
on the wrong side and i felt bad about
it i'm actually going to go to the
effort of reaching out to you and
telling you that i actually have figured
it out right
so
there is the possibility
for people who broke the wrong way to do
the soul searching later right but but
the point about the statute of
limitations is that what will happen in
short order is that now it's very
visceral right right we remember what
people tweeted and what they said and
you know what they published and all of
that and that will become murky and it
will go back to feeling like oh yeah you
know it's gonna be this sort of loose
heuristic on you know
who makes sense when in fact at the
moment it's very clear that a lot of
people failed the test
so weren't actually engaged in the
activity of trying to derive meaning
from first principles in the first place
even though they appeared to be those
people because they fell
anti-woke for instance because they fell
anti-the hashtag black lives matter of
course black lives actually matter but
not that movement not here not now right
they fell the right way because they saw
something in that that really didn't
feel right but it was it like doesn't
feel right it was based on
some other kind of god this sounds
ridiculous but like way of knowing and
it wasn't based in analysis and it
wasn't based in scientific thinking and
it wasn't based in numeracy and i guess
part of what is is revealing over and
over and over again is how functionally
enumerate and scientifically illiterate
and
not just
anti-analytical but just like
functionally analytical so many people
are that they just they just couldn't
even manage to do it they couldn't even
get close to it
because some dude who's practically just
like holding glassware wearing a lab
coat goes trust the science follow the
science
yeah i mean
it's it's just it's so disheartening
it's disheartening it's disheartening
but um
here
oh yeah so many things um
laurie garrett
um
author of the coming plague right from a
long time ago
um who has not um
done a brilliant job throughout this
uh
quote tweets
the new silent majority the fully vaxxed
of an atlantic article
um
which let's see i didn't pull it up for
the silent this is uh a atlantic article
published a few days ago the silent
vaccinated impatient majority
as patients with epidemic wanes leaders
and widely vaccinated democracies
deploying a new political strategy
and it proceeds to explain
how
those who are vaccinated just fed up
with those of us who aren't and it's our
fault well they're continuing the
pandemic of the unvaccinate even
now i mean this is what is it the 21st
or 22nd even now um it's like four or
five days ago
even now even now well but when the the
efficacy of these things is so clearly
through the floor
right and you're gonna get on your high
horse
about being impatient with those of us
who resisted your crap treatment
well it's it's you know
dog whistle is an overused term but it's
a dog whistle for people who were
gullible enough to fall for that line in
the first place and the point is you
know
i at least have some sympathy for people
who didn't know what to do didn't know
who to listen to
and
you know said well
there
these people
who have all of the things that are
supposed to indicate that they're
scientifically credible are telling me
that they've looked at the evidence
they've looked at the safety they've
looked at the efficacy and that i should
get this thing right yeah but are you
sympathetic to people who are still now
this week saying well i did everything
right and i'm just really fed up with
the people who didn't because it's their
fault look am sympathetic with anybody
who didn't have the tools to make sense
of it that's not sympathetic with people
who did have the tools and decided not
to use them well but i guess
and this again it's really hard to
discriminate between can't and won't
but part of what i am
wrestling with at the moment is
the reveal
that so many people among the so-called
intelligentsia the chattering classes of
the coasts
either cannot or will not engage in what
for us
as people who think scientifically every
day of our lives by second nature doing
analysis
and just
basic hypothesis generation and an
attempt to look into the actual data in
so far as it's been available
there's been almost none of that is it a
can't or won't i don't know well but i
mean this went down
uh through the careful use of incentives
yeah right and the whole point the whole
reason
that
the
that the experience was from our side
what it was
had to do with the fact that what was
really being said to people
is
look at them
there but for the grace of god go you
now the way that you stay out of that
position is you don't explore in this
way so to the extent that somebody put
very frightening stuff in the path of
those who might otherwise have been open
to an analysis
you know
i don't respect
not thinking because somebody is trying
to scare you away from thinking but i
understand it right right right and
depending upon who you are you know a
lot of people were isolated they did not
know that's true who was making sense
and
you know it's not simple yep right
um
so okay i've i've taken the atlantic to
task a lot um over the last
year or two in part because i'm super
disappointed in it because it was um it
was it was one of my first literary
loves and i was treated well by it early
on
and um and this zachary if you would
show this this is the article i just
showed the silent vaccine and patient
minor majority well i'm old enough to
remember when the atlantic was
publishing articles like this 2010 did
pfizer bribe its way out of criminal
charges in nigeria wikileaks cables shed
new light into one of big pharma's
darkest hours
and i'm just going to read it was a date
on that 2010
uh just read the first paragraph here on
day 12 of wikileaks release of u.s state
department cables the daily drip drip
drip of diplomatic secrets implicated
the pharmaceutical industry the company
was pfizer the country was nigeria and
the context was the long simmering still
bitter aftermath of the drug drug of the
drug giant's quick and dirty 1996 trials
of an experimental antibiotic for
children during a devastating meningitis
outbreak a truly chilling cautionary
tale of industry-funded clinical trials
in the developing world this event is
recalled in the west mainly as
inspiration for john le carre's evil
pharma thriller the constant gardener
so the constant gardener is one of the
two films that we watched this week zach
if i may have my screen back thank you
um which
uh is
extraordinary and and and you know also
won all sorts of awards for its sort of
artistic and and narrative skill um
so 2005 film based on the 2001 john le
carre novel of the same name um and
interestingly so that atlantic article
suggests that is understood and there is
a lot of stuff that suggests that lacari
really was loosely basing this on
on what happened with pfizer in nigeria
but at the end of the film
there was a quote from le carre that
said that reads
nobody in this story and no outfitter
corporation thank god is based upon an
actual person or outfit in the real
world
but i can tell you this
as my journey through the pharmaceutical
jungle progressed i came to realize that
by comparison with the reality my story
was as tame as a holiday postcard
i recommend this movie
i recommend this movie highly and i also
recommend the movie you watched last
night which we had seen before but we
watched with our boys for the first time
which is dallas buyer's club
a 213 2013 movie um so-called
biographical drama
based on the real life story of ron
woodruff um uh
story takes place in the mid to late
1980s during the aids crisis
um
and at the end of the movie the quote
there interesting about both of these
movies there are quotes at the end that
you don't typically see um the likes of
at the end of movies at the end of this
movie
we have aids is not over
access to treatment could save many more
lives
uh and
you know dallas buyers club doesn't have
anything to do with africa but there's a
there's a common theme here in terms of
what kind of medical
capers have actually happened in africa
and who is actually being harmed and
what the people who are doing the harm
sound like when they talk about what
they're doing there and it's almost
always exactly the opposite of what
they're actually doing
i think this
is a
piece of the puzzle here that we are
never
going to have an easy time conveying
which is that there is a process
in normal business there is a
um
a positive feedback
right where
i've used the example of you know if
you're going to design the interior of a
car
you're going to make decisions that are
going to result in certain people dying
right because if you were to design a
car in which you made every decision
such that you know it had no downsides
the car would be impossibly expensive
and then possibly gas guzzling and so
you know there are trade-offs
but the point is once you are in the
world of trade-offs where the point is
your decisions have the result and
result in somebody's
death here and there and you start
getting comfortable with that as part of
the process there's no end to it and so
pharmaceutical companies run trials
these trials involve people dying from
medications because you need to know how
safe the thing is and obviously a
medication could be wonderfully valuable
and have a certain amount of
harm in the form of people dying who
have particular predispositions or
whatever right so the point is there's a
there's a utilitarian metric
by which you get an allowance
for for doing terrible things to people
and the point is once you get
comfortable with that
as these films obviously reveal
um you know one in the case of an
african trial and the other in the case
of
um the absurd use of azt earlier in the
in the aids and the refusal of fda to
allow any other kinds of treatment
right a familiar pattern but the point
is once
pharma or any other industry gets used
to the carnage that results from
business as usual the point is then it
becomes a question of scale
yeah right and that's what we saw here
is a brand new scale of something that
actually isn't remarkable for pharma it
happens all the time it just this time
it involved all of us
yeah this this went full global um
typically they have restricted
themselves to a continent
right but
but my point is
all of the
things that people are having a hard
time believing actually could possibly
have happened i mean what protected the
pharma effort here was that it was
impossible to believe that people would
do this to other humans and that's what
kind of lie was it
right was it noble
what it was was business as usual at a
scale that has never been seen at an
absolutely unprecedented scale right
and that is actually a story that we
need to wrap our minds around right that
this is happening all the time with
other diseases and other drugs and
um you know often far enough out of your
view that it seems very very remote
right
um but
uh
anyway
the scale caught us off guard and
hopefully it's woken us up
i hope so
um
i will say that i came home i was out um
working at a coffee shop and then
walking
and
trying
trying to be christian trying to be
forgiving and i was not managing it i
was pretty pretty worked up
and i came home
and i
discovered that tiknot han had died
and
um he was 95 he was
a a buddhist monk who many
found
solace and meaning in and i spoke about
him a bit in it turns out episode 62
almost exactly a year ago actually
january 9 2022 in an episode that we
called tyranny comes at you fast
and um as i said then my experience i
actually i actually spent two weeks with
the man uh when i was a 17 year old the
high school that you and i met at brett
uh had these um senior
i don't even know how it was framed but
they gave you sort of two weeks to um do
something um creative or you know to
take time to do something by which you
would become a better human being
um i believe you
my friend kim and i went to death valley
and uh did black and white photography
yeah fabulous
um and i can't remember like anyone
else's i knew that i thought it was
death valley i wasn't sure
um
and i my amazing creative writing
teacher who i don't think was then but
is now a buddhist himself a i think a
buddhist monk
um
got me into
this uh buddhist artist retreat up in
ojai where i was the only kid you know i
was a 17 year old as a young woman
and there are all these beat poets and
then some other um some other artists as
well some 2d and 3d artists and tiknot
han
who in for two weeks led us in three
sitting in one walking meditation a day
and then we were you know making the
place run we were
you know breaking bread together and all
of this and then and then doing our art
whatever it was and you know my art at
that time i began to do some ceramics
but it was it was it was words it was
writing and it was sleeping in tents and
such
and i got to hang out with beat poets
and take not han and it was
remarkable
and i haven't
i i didn't think of myself as a as a
buddhist then and i haven't since and i
haven't really meditated um
but i have seen the value in
sort of finding
finding a place finding a calmness and
um and his words certainly are
um illuminating with regard to the
damage that fear
and anger do
and so i went back to the same book that
i read from back in episode 62 fear
essential wisdom for getting through the
storm
again this man is is dead
today at the age of 95 and i just wanted
to read a couple of of brief sections
from this
appreciating where we are
imagine two astronauts go to the moon
and while they're there there's an
accident and their ship can't take them
back to earth
they have only enough oxygen for two
days there is no hope of someone coming
from earth in time to rescue them they
have only two days to live
if you were to ask them at the moment
what is your deepest wish they would
answer to be back home walking on our
beautiful planet earth
that would be enough for them
they wouldn't want anything else they
wouldn't think of being the head of a
large corporation a famous celebrity or
the president of the united states they
wouldn't want anything but to be back
there walking on earth enjoying every
step listening to the sounds of nature
or holding the hand of their beloved
while contemplating the moon at night
we should live every day like people who
have just been rescued from dying on the
moon
we are on earth now and we need to enjoy
walking on this precious beautiful
planet
zen master lingi said quote the miracle
is not to walk on water or fire the
miracle is to walk on the earth
i cherish that teaching i enjoy just
walking even in busy places like
airports and railway stations
walking like that with each step
caressing our mother earth we can
inspire other people to do the same
we can enjoy every minute of our lives
and one more brief that's uh
beautifully described in fact yeah and i
i would argue actually you can
get a different version of that by
looking at mundane creatures
absolutely every one of which is a
miracle oh yeah right you just don't
realize how amazing a house fly is right
but even a housefly if you stop to take
the time to look at it um
there's a lifetime's worth of
fascination in it yeah i'd rather not
land on my drink but okay oh yeah sure i
mean it's immoral on the part of the fly
no i i think they're deeply into amoral
territory
okay uh the conditions of happiness
from again the book fear essential
wisdom for getting through the storm by
tiknot han
the conditions of happiness there are so
many conditions of happiness available
in the present moment you can take a
piece of paper and a pencil and write
them all down
in the beginning you may think your list
won't be very long
but you'll be surprised to find that
even both sides of the paper aren't
enough for writing down all the
conditions of happiness that are already
available
when we look at our own body and the
environment we can identify many
conditions of happiness that are already
available hundreds thousands of them
for example your eyes are a condition of
happiness when you have eyes still in
good condition you need only to open
them to see a paradise of shapes and
colors
when we've lost our eyesight we
recognize that to have good vision is a
wonder
so your good eyesight is already a
condition of happiness thanks to your
eyes being in good condition this whole
paradise is available to you if you
touch this condition with awareness
happiness naturally arises
there are innumerable other wonders just
like that in your life for example there
is your heart breathing in i am aware of
my heart with mindfulness you recognize
the presence of your heart breathing in
i know my heart is there and i'm very
happy
to have a heart that functions normally
is a great happiness
when you've worked a long shift you may
have a chance to take a rest but your
heart never stops working it's beating
for you 24 hours a day
your heart is healthy and working for
you that's a wonderful thing
there are those among us who don't have
such a heart who are always afraid of
having a heart attack or some other
emergency
there's nothing in the world they want
more than to have a normal heart just
like the one you have
so you breathe and recognize the
presence of your heart and you are
touching another condition of happiness
breathing in i'm aware of my heart
breathing out i smile to my heart with a
lot of gratitude you're touching another
condition of happiness you can touch
hundreds of conditions of happiness
right there in your own body and mind as
well as around you
it helped me it helped me uh
get out of my
anger and despondency
yeah it's um
i i
i don't want to sum it up but there is
some aspect of this that has to do
with
uh
outwitting your evolutionary program
through
good calibration yeah right we we are
designed not to pay attention to house
flies we are designed not to be noticing
every step we are designed to be doing
all kinds of things
and we are designed for an environment
we don't live in so that design is
almost completely arbitrary with respect
to what you should actually be paying
attention to
and you know
mindfulness doesn't cut it the problem
with mindfulness is that it's too
general right but what he's arguing
there
is
you know that from another vantage point
something that you have which you are
taking
that you are taking for granted almost
every moment of every day of your life
would be a reason for great joy where
you're just simply in a slightly
different spot and therefore you know
you can tune into that anytime you like
and i mean you've talked about this
with regard to
what it felt like waiting for the boat
to come back after the accident in
galapagos right when it wasn't
no one would talk to you and it wasn't
clear if i had survived yep and you had
the sense of maybe this is the moment
before which and after which everything
is different
and just and you know for me having
lived through the experience and then of
course the years and years of
aftermath rehabilitation and everything
um but for both of us the like
everything could have changed right then
brings you back into sharp relief
of appreciation and gratitude
for
so many of the things that you had
perhaps forgotten to be recognizing or
grateful for yeah in fact it's weird i
hate to introduce it because in some
sense it almost suggests the opposite
lesson which i don't want to do because
i know it's the right lesson but
the
um
so for those who aren't aware of the
story heather had been
gravely injured in a terrible boat
accident in galapagos and word had made
it back that there were injuries that
not everyone was okay
but nobody would tell me anything and
the more i asked questions the more it
became clear that something had happened
to heather that there wasn't information
and so
you know i ran to the dock and waited
for the boat with the injured to arrive
and the more i learned
the more it seemed likely that
you were probably gone and
um
you know there is this i don't think
there will be another period in my life
like it there was a period of you know
40 minutes where it's like
i don't know this to be a fact i can't
find any evidence that it isn't true i
am i'm hovering in that place you know
between two
completely opposite realities that will
you know immediately kick loose as as
the boat arrives and
you know and it was worse when the boat
did arrive because you were injured
enough that you were lying down in the
boat so you weren't even visible so as
you know i pulled out my binoculars and
i'm trying to understand what has
happened you can see all of our students
but not me seems to confirm the worst
and then uh
our student val gets off the boat in
absolute tears over what she's been
through and so i think i see in her eyes
confirmation of the worst right
in any case
the
profound relief upon you being carried
off the boat and speaking to me
um
was it was like this moon thing where
it's like okay
right
doesn't matter what else is true
right because the point is what isn't
true that the horrifying possibility
that has just vanished
is is such a relief that it was like
i don't think i saw as clearly as i
needed to
how badly hurt you were because the
point was you were alive and you were
clearly going to make it well i wonder
actually i feel like
that's exactly sort of where i was going
is that um
i didn't
know that i was going to survive at that
point it felt very much like it was
possible that i had punctured a realm
with a rum
along with one of what i knew to be
multiple broken ribs among all the other
injuries and um
and so there was like this series of
step functions where i was like oh my
god now i need to somehow compel i need
to put the information out into the
universe
that i am
not certain
i am alive now i did not die back there
i'm alive right now but it's not clear
that that will be the case and somehow
there's this vigilance and i think maybe
that's maybe that is actually kind of
mirrored in what i'm feeling right now
around
the the public health response and the
and the pandemic if you will in all this
i'm just feeling this like anxiousness
this vigilance like oh my god
must communicate the thing that needs to
be communicated so that
so that the worst doesn't happen because
as awful as these two years has been
it becomes even worse if things get
instantiated as a result if the if if
the new if the new regime is the people
who have crowned themselves with exactly
the same systems that got us into the
situation in the first place yeah if the
scramble in the middle ground allows the
thing that did us
this way to continue to be in power then
the point is we are inviting the next
one and
i agree
we are weirdly hovering in this middle
spot now where the narrative cannot hold
it's coming apart right and you and i
are feeling a great deal of relief over
that because that narrative has been
pointed at us for two years
and yet not relief
exactly i actually do feel
i hadn't occurred to me but i actually
do feel that same sort of visceral
anxiety without the excruciating
physical pain associated with the um
really just the hours between
landing on that dock and and being
assured by the good doctor stefania um
that no i was going to survive um but
there there was time in there like i
don't know and no one no one else is
aware like help like no one else can
hear the truth of what i know is going
on and that was entirely about my body
but this feels like the body politic
like watch this everyone must have eyes
on this and not let it happen again well
it's interesting i didn't see this
connection coming at all but i
absolutely think this is where we are
and i have had multiple conversations
with people who have taken
you know
some
prominent people
who have taken a tremendous amount of
[ __ ] over
revealing
again and again and being you know
courageous in the face of what came back
at them
people are feeling
relief
and i
hate to be the one who says actually i
mean you know i was kidding at the
beginning of the podcast
but i do think this is the halfway point
because the point is it wasn't about the
pathogen to begin with the pathogen was
real
something rode that pathogen and that
something's fate now hangs in the
balance and
it is now going to react like a
um
a threatened ferocious creature and
people need to understand that that's
coming otherwise
it will stay in power yeah i think
that's right
well okay
um
we are going to sign off
and um
take a 50 minute break or so for those
um
who aren't sticking around for the q a
or who are listening on audio only
podcast where the q a doesn't show up
we'll be back in a week next week i
forgot to say it again at the start of
the hour next week we'll be coming to
you early on friday pacific time
something like 8 30 or 9 is that what we
agreed on zach
um
yeah
um
something something early pacific time
but if you're with us right now
or you're on video
and and
boy i lost it ask questions at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
and
that's for questions you want us to
answer if you have logistical questions
like hey i heard they have a p.o box
we've been getting some just
lovely communications and
packages as well from people
our darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
can point you to that address right now
the question asking period is open on my
patreon for a private monthly q a
um
as always consider
consider reading this
we're proud of it and we think it does a
lot of the heavy lifting of the kinds of
thinking that we're talking about here
hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century evolution and the challenges of
modern life
and
be good to the good ones
yeah
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside
see you soon be well everyone
[Music]
you